From movies to theme parks to all sorts of
merchandise, it’s hard to escape Disney
and when you are a company as big as they
are, you’re bound to have some rumors circling
around you.
There’s a lot of crazy stories about Disney
that people have believed as truth for a long
time – but that’s about to end!
We are debunking some of the biggest false
Disney facts that people believe in our latest
list.
Enjoy the video and be sure to subscribe to
Screen Rant and join the notification squad
to stay up to date with everything we have
to offer.
Here are 10 False Disney Facts Adults Always
Thought Were True
The Magic Kingdom's Space Mountain decapitated
a rider
If you have been to Disney World, you have
probably been on the Space Mountain ride as
it is as famous and is it fun.
For years a story has been circling about
a panicked guest who stood up during the ride
and was decapitated by a low hanging metal
bar.
Thankfully, this is merely an urban legend,
most likely created by adults to try to keep
their kids from standing up.
Even then, the ride has passengers pretty
securely strapped in so it would be very difficult
for a rider to stand up.
While this is a crazy story that would definitely
add a dangerous allure to the famed ride,
we are happy that no one actually got hurt!
Walt Disney’s Fortune
This is a very strange rumor surround Walt
Disney’s remaining fortune and although
it has many variations, they all boil down
to one idea: Walt Disney left a large sum
of money to the first man to become pregnant.
Some people have claimed that the sum would
be 10 million dollars while others have suggested
that it was the entire Disney estate.
If this sounds too crazy to be true, that’s
probably because it is as Disney's will and
testament has been well documented online
and makes no mention of a prize for a pregnant
man.
The breakdown of the will indicates that his
enormous fortune is to be divided between
his family and the charities that Disney funds.
The Little Mermaid
For years, the Internet has been up in arms
about the wedding scene from The Little Mermaid
as they claim that the minister is sporting
a visible erection.
This rumor got so out of hand that one woman
even sued Disney due to the emotional trauma
she incurred from the experience.
All of this commotion is actually just non
sense as if you look carefully, the offensive
bulge is actually just the minister's knees
protruding through his cloak.
We can understand how this image could cause
some confusion, but it’s not the dirty moment
that people have been claiming it is.
Just to be safe, Disney re-edited the scene
to cut out the controversial bulge and put
a stop to all the false rumors.
Cinderella Castle can be dismantled if a hurricane
is approaching
This rumor is a strange one as it is believed
by many that in the event of a major hurricane,
the Magic Kingdom's iconic Cinderella Castle
can be quickly broken down and safely stored
away.
We don’t really know why this story exists
as dismantling the iconic Cinderella Castle
would be a major operation and could not be
neatly taken down in an emergency.
The castle took 18 months to construct and
is made up of an enormous amount of steel
and concrete that would definitely not come
down easily.
While it’s nice to think that this castle
would be preserved under any circumstances,
there is no way it can be quickly disassembled
like an Ikea bookcase.
Toy Story Characters
One of the best parts of going to the Disney
parks is getting to see all your favorite
characters in real life.
There is actually a rumor that If you yell
"Andy's coming!" at Toy Story characters at
Walt Disney World, they will stop what they
are doing and lie flat on the ground (like
the toys do in the movie).
Sadly, this was proved to be false and a Disney
spokesperson explained that although it would
be a fun trick, the idea of seeing these giant
characters flopping around on the ground isn’t
something the company wants to promote in
their parks.
However, just because it doesn’t happen
all the time, doesn’t mean some Disney employees
haven’t had a little fun as there is reportedly
some video evidence of these characters acting
out the “Andy is coming!” moment.
Tinker Bell Based On Marilyn Monroe
Peter Pan is one of the most famous Disney
movies of all time and the story of the boy
who never grows up has sparked numerous spinoffs
and reboots.
Peter Pant also introduced us to Tinker Bell,
one of the mischievous characters Disney has
ever created and she also happens to be at
the center of popular fake rumor.
For years it has been believed that the magical
pixie from Peter Pan was modeled after the
famous actress Marilyn Monroe, but this is
actually completely untrue.
In fact, Tink was actually modeled after Margaret
Kelly, the actress behind the animated character.
Frozen Walt
For years it has been believed by many that
Walt Disney was cryogenically frozen after
his death, which is a pretty creepy idea.
The popular myth actually states that Walt
Disney was frozen and stashed underneath the
Pirates Of The Caribbean ride inside the Disney
park, but thankfully this is nothing but an
old wives tale.
The story of frozen Walt has been proven false
as there is thorough documentation showing
that Walt was cremated just two days after
his death.
This is a very strange rumor and we have to
wonder who started it and why…Disney conspiracy
perhaps?!
The Tower of Terror
The Tower of Terror is one of the best rides
at Disney World, but there has been a rumor
circling the famed attraction that has made
it even more terrifying.
"Proof" that the Tower of Terror was really
haunted surfaced in a YouTube video allegedly
showing a ghost on the ride during an after-hours
maintenance check.
Unfortunately, while this was a cool video,
it doesn’t confirm any paranormal activity.
The video looks more like some dust and reflections,
but we can see how people could be tricked
by this hoax.
We are guessing that this rumor has only made
the ride more popular and we suspect it may
have even been a clever marketing ploy created
by Disney itself.
Donald Duck
This rumor is definitely one of the most bizarre
ones that we have ever heard, but unfortunately,
it is totally phony.
A few years ago there was a story circling
around that the famous Disney duck was completely
banned in Finland due to the fact that he
wears no pants.
While this rumor is nuts, the real story is
even weirder as it turned out to be a fake
story that was propagated by the media in
an effort to make the Finnish liberal party
look crazy and over protective.
We understand that politics can be a game
on manipulation sometimes, but please, please
leave Donald Duck and his wacky antics out
of it!
Lion King
It’s a well known fact that Disney likes
to slip some adult jokes and messages into
their films but it turns out that audiences
may have been tricked into thinking something
in the Lion King was much dirtier than it
actually is.
For years, people have believed that the word
“SEX” appears on screen made up of dust
floating in the air, but this is actually
false.
The dust does spell out a word, but that word
is actually “SFX”.
Why?
Well this is actually a sneaky shout out to
the special effects department that worked
hard on the film.
We can’t blame people for getting this one
wrong, though, as the two words are admittedly
very similar.
So there you have it, there is our rumor busting
list of 10 False Disney Facts Adults Always
Thought Were True.
We apologize is we busted anyone’s bubbles
here – but the truth must be told!
Which one of these myth-busting stories shocked
you the most?
What other Disney rumors have you heard about?
Let us know what you think in the comments
section down below and be sure to subscribe
to Screen Rant for more fun videos – like
this one!